hello and welcome to this video playing
I am it's why who is that
let me see it doesn't have a name in
there okay
I would I would have thought that you
needed them to have the name of your own
and I am here but okay it's not a big
deal I keep forgetting that yeah of
course I'm I did this banker gambit
repertoire for for chess table but I'm
haven't looked at it for a long while
so I keep forgetting keep forgetting
lines can be annoying and you know that
hmm this is supposed to be okay for
black girl and like why exactly these
kind of things they tend to happen
I remember that here night 85 I can play
Knight takes e4 Knight d5 I mean and
that should be okay I don't think white
gets the dreaded a 495 in anymore and
then you usually okay b3
[Music]
okay you always have to check like if a
four is going to be possible or or not
hmm
I can play rook to rook a to b6 to
prevent it honestly I don't think it's
such a big deal because after a 497
there is no Knight b5 and then I can
actually I threaten rook b6 and he has
to work a little bit to get his pieces
coordinated like the bishop cannot
easily move and allow ninety two he
would like to play 90 to c4 of course
but it's not so quickly done one idea
that yacht's always have to keep in mind
in such a position is c4
if White has to take oftentimes you can
simply trade down all pawns like c4
partakes takes c3 you take a four you
take c4 later
here it is not really that important to
set yeah but it is some part of this
position type I'm not entirely certain
what white is going to do now to be
perfectly honest
how does he save the b3 born
I'm just threatening okay b6 and if I
win that porn I'm most likely going to
be quite a bit better as the Acorn small
weak than anything else yeah I was
thinking about that but still have a
hard time to believe it
if I go night sorry if I go ruku b6 mmm
that's not really
interesting I can do many so it's a very
complex position I also have f5 which is
quite interesting
meaning let's let's put this first and
f5 to undermine the whole the whole
structure
I also have this move that was my
original intention so let's do it on a
night move I can take a form night b5 I
can take with the rock take on be to
take b5 I get the pawn back with a good
position and I'm simply threatening
Bishop c3 rookie form which would win
probably both pawns yeah not a happy
move for him but probably what he had to
do okay look could be five or night b5
that is not such an easy choice Knight
eggs look strong either as well before I
have c4 which is very strong and a
threatened Knight f6 now which would win
if form yeah that is definitely quite a
substantial threat Knight f6 should we
nee form so he is preparing night to t2
here
[Music]
okay
okay I mean I can do this and go ahead
five which should nevertheless win one
of the center points and there's some
really nice typical Benko who knew was
in there maybe I missed some more
concrete things I'm not missing this one
though okay and that looked like like a
model bingo game at least on the surface
if you dig deeper you might find
problems okay so we got this one
important point here was that night b5
can be answered with 94 which should be
okay for black and now he traded and
played b3 yeah if you go a four here I
think black should be fine black is
active enough to make sure that white
does not get the night p5 Block in so in
the game b3 rook b8 no a for again and
here yeah okay I was I thought I can
actually allow a four which I did not
necessarily needed to do where I could
play okay three or something but okay
98-84 97 I know I was thinking I have
this idea and potentially a five and it
should be fine
92 was that was not on my radar
so f5
very interesting
yeah f5 gets traded for d5 I'm very
active but it's not entirely clear
so look between this good now right
even f5 is good okay that would be six
should be fine as well here and rupee
for us also good yeah okay
now b5 oh I can take on e4 I didn't see
that but this is a good line right take
take take and now everything is good
knight takes the ideas said after before
I've got the very nice move c4 over c2
c3 for example is very strong yes this
is a pin so that's good there should be
three 93 92 f5 and white is completely
exploding in the center and f3 was
losing a more material bit if he takes I
just recapture and this is just falling
the bishop only three years often times
in pretty useless piece in such a
position I mean such a position this is
very specific but I mean like in the
banco in those Bank of positions
sometimes this bishop doesn't really
have much of a much of the role if it
cannot defend the center and sometimes
it finds itself yeah being quite useless
in fact and at the end that was an
example of that because now the bishop
cannot shoot this and it is generally
not attacking anything the Knights here
black slides are just far better yeah
thanks a lot for watching